hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on new world today and
we got some stuff to talk about today
there was a new video I told you in the
last video that we talked about a new
world that there were going to be
uploading a video following their blog
post about the stuff that they mentioned
and today is that video it's not going
to any groundbreaking like 30 minutes of
gameplay thing it's a three and a half
minute video with small little bits of
stuff talked about in it so I thought
we'd go over especially for people like
me and others like you guys probably
watching at home that honestly have no
clue a new world is about and have never
got the chance to play because you
didn't know about it until the Alpha was
already finished so we kind of get to
see a little bit more about the game
there's always like the B if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new and let's
get started with today's video I'm gonna
be saving the end of the video for my
general thoughts but a way to basically
how they explain how we start the game
in the very beginning is gonna be kind
of your typical MMO in a sense we're
ship crashes and you're left on the
beach and you're stuck at ground zero
I believe path of Exile also did this to
I and I believe black desert did this as
well I haven't played path of Exile in
years so I could actually be totally
wrong with that but it is definitely not
a original formula but I mean it's a
tried-and-true thing so it's it's
definitely a good thing to do they also
mentioned from a story perspective that
nothing really dies in the world of
eights Arnim it's pretty much this
magical essence call the Azoth that
keeps everything alive and which is kind
of the main reason why they're
explaining this because of course you
know when us as players die i ever going
to be respawning so i think they're
using that as a way of trying to make it
so that it's realistic in a sense that
we keep respawning and not just a
obvious gameplay mechanic which i think
is not too bad but it also explains why
some of the creatures respawn because
their soul doesn't actually leave the
body or actually disappear it just kind
of comes back and that's because of that
magical essence which is called Azoff
now the main kind of antagonist to the
player is pretty much going to be what's
called the corrupted those are going to
be these cuts of demon type of people
you'll see this in typical MMOs it's the
enemies that always just for some odd
reason have millions and millions of
armies and they all teleport in one
location and just swarm you kind of that
typical thing those are gonna be
actually how they transport which we'll
get into a little bit later but the
first faction that we learn about is
called the lost and there this is a kind
of
undead innocence faction they are all
alive like everybody in the world is
except they technically don't have a
soul so they're in this alive not alive
kind of a livable purgatory in a sense
of in this endless fate of just them
being this undead creature and it's very
painful for that specific being a good
way to summarize this if you're not
going to remember all that info is
pretty much there the undead or the
ghouls of many games that we've seen in
the past this is going to be their
version of their take on it the second
faction is called the angry earth they
kind of look more like tree people
Spriggans from skyrim is probably the
best example I can give here a lot of
different tree kind of bark armor that
they're gonna be wearing lots of stuff
made around plants and they also live in
kind of the forest the area and they're
pretty much the Earth's defenders and
they're going to be fighting against the
corruption and kind of why it's plaguing
them and they want to just get rid of
all of it because they think that's
their duty - they're pretty much like
the Earth's defenders and there's going
to be a combination of humanoid looking
creatures but also these weird-ass
monstrosities a good example of those
that's from the angry earth is in the
trailer that we saw which are also
seeing in this video as well was that
deer that we saw in the beginning next
to that giant head that looked all sorts
of [ __ ] weird with branches and
glowing eyes that is part of the angry
earth weather that was made by one of
the members of it or that's just kind of
the soul that went into that body that's
kind of what they represent the other
faction that they brought up which I
don't necessarily know if this is a
faction because they never actually
stated it was a group called the
ancients they were way way long before
our time and they actually ended up
trying to harness the power of a zoth
which is that magical essence that keeps
everyone immortal in the world and they
use that to go really high in technology
and just kind of skyrocket their
environment and their technological
advancements well the problem is that
they've been gone for a very very long
time and no one really knows what's
happened to the ancients so there's
gonna be a bunch of ruins for you to
discover and kind of figure out there so
that could be its own little lore
segment in itself and also there's going
to be a bunch of people from other
factions and such or you know I saw I
think in the trailer there was like an
undead person so he could have been part
of the loss but also maybe pays tribute
to the ancients in his spare time and
then lastly what we have is the
corrupted like I told you these are
going to be those enemies
just kind of portal up and maybe block a
road or it's right in the middle of your
territory and boom lows in waves of
these enemies fight against the player
it's basically a tournament fighting
against you and it's gonna be to get to
that point because we talked about in
the last video how there was a few pvp
and PVE invasions one of the PvE
invasions on territories is the
corrupted go and try to swarm your
territory and that's what this is going
to be basically and you're gonna be
seeing a little bit of gameplay in the
background I'm unsure if this is
actually what the PvE stuff is going to
look like or if this is just two rival
factions fighting it out but regardless
that's gonna be kind of a little bit of
the combat in terms of faction fighting
but yeah there will be some PvE events
so so especially if you're the governor
or whatever you happen to be within the
town definitely make sure that the
corrupted stay away from your territory
overall I think this is a pretty nice
video it's only three and a half minutes
which kind of sucks and a lot of people
were definitely displaying a lot of
their issues one of my issues is that I
am not really a big fan of the very kind
of cop-out intro of we washed up on a
shore and we're on this new world I can
kind of understand how it's just an easy
way to get through and to kind of
continue on the story in world-building
I've just never really been a big fan of
that but also it's probably gonna be
like five minutes in the very beginning
in the game so honestly nothing really
too crazy to really look like uninstall
the game for but something that a lot of
people especially in the comments I've
mentioned judging by the 160 likes and
the 69 dislikes that there wasn't a lot
of information and a lot of gameplay it
was kind of just more story building
which is totally fine but there wasn't a
lot of you know gameplay issue mechanics
shown and there was barely any gameplay
shown and the game is only a couple
months away from release and a lot of
people are expecting at least a trailer
or something with gameplay and I think
that's fair obviously we have the
upcoming closed beta which if you
pre-ordered the game you should get the
ability to do that whether it's the 30
or $40 Edition I don't think it matters
I'm pretty sure you get access to the
beta from there or you just hopefully
get a code in the future but I mean
that's gonna be where most of the
gameplay is gonna come from but it's
also kind of nice to see from their side
about the gameplay right we they talk
about certain mechanics that we know
those mechanics going into the beta and
we can discover more things instead of
just
starting from Ground Zero and that we
really don't get anywhere in that month
that we have the beta it seems like
these devs are definitely gonna be
trying to push out a lot more content
when it comes to these blog posts in
these dev videos before the game's
release so I'm expecting at least one of
these to be about the gameplay mechanics
of the game hopefully we get one of
those that would be phenomenal I would
love to actually show gameplay of this
to everybody on the channel here that I
think they'd be phenomenal but yeah let
me know what you guys think about the
stuff in the comments below like the
video if you do enjoy but with that guys
take care have a greatest today
hopefully I'll see you in the next New
World video and peace out
you